[音楽]
[拍手]
何か
新しいアイデアを見つけた時あー見つけた
めっちゃ嬉しいで僕は思います
何か
うまくできなかった時
あーマジで悔しいで僕は思います
嬉しいとか
悔しいとか
この
五感で目の前に出来事から
感じる感情は今
皆さんが行っている行動の
原動力になっているのではないでしょうか
しながら年齢を重ねて
忙しく
生きる中で
嬉しいとか
悔しいとかそういう感情を
過去のどこかに
置き去りにしてしまったなんてこともまた
多くの皆さんは
経験しているのではないでしょうか
私自身も
幼い頃は思った感情のままに行動できてい
たのに
年齢を重ねるうちなんかどこか自分の感情
を
置き去りにしてしまったなんてことがあり
ました
そんな中最近
感情を抱いた時にこのような言葉を思い
ます
感情には
賞味期限があるよ
賞味期限があるよってことです
少し皆さんの頭の中でこの意味を考えてみ
てください
この言葉は
僕が自分の感情が
わからなくなってしまった時に
友人が
くれた言葉でした
今日はこの
感情には
賞味期限があるよっていう言葉をお話をし
たいと思います
幼い頃
泥は食べちゃダメよって
当たり前のように言われてきましたでも
綺麗な泥団子を作った時にあ
泥ってどんな味がするんだっけちょっと気
になるなと思って
好奇心旺盛な僕は
食べてしまいました
もちろんまずくて吐き出してないでしまう
そんな状況を見た
知った親はそんな
ドラマ食べちゃダメだよっていうことなく
そっかまずかったねじゃあ
泥は食べれないねって
僕がいいなって思ったことを
ちゃんとしなよってそう肯定してくれる
ような
素晴らしい
親の元で僕は育ちました
そんな
僕は10代でも
相変わらず
スマートフォンを見て
うわーなんか幸せそうな恋人が映っていい
笑顔だな
僕も旅したいで思って
そのまま
貯金を叩いて
Amazonで
安い自転車をポチって1週間後に
熊本から北海道まで行きました
九州から一人出たこともなかったし
自転車正直あんまり好きじゃなかったです
よね
だから
正直一番のこの旅の記憶はお尻が痛かった
なーってことです
でもこの旅の中で出会った人や
素晴らしい景色は今も僕の中のかけがえ
ない記憶です
ある時はあなんかずっと自分に本意住ん
でるよな
海外に住んだ時
自分は何を思うんだろうどうなるんだろう
で思って
よしじゃあカナダイスもやって
オーストラリアに行きました
オーストラリアでは
働いてお金を貯めて
自分の車を買って
オーストラリアの
右から
左まで45度
ぐらいの
砂漠の中を
駆け抜けるそんな旅をしました
まあその後にちょっと色々あってお金が
なくなってしまってこの絵の中のように2
ヶ月間1人の友人と車の中で生活をしまし
た
ビーチサイドに住んでて毎日バーベキュー
三昧そう
洗濯物とかコインランドリーもなかったん
でバケツの中に汚れた服と洗剤入れて今時
足踏みしちゃってでなんか洗った後パワー
ウィンドウに挟んで
乾燥させるみたいな今絶対しないような
ことをこの時にして
正直車の中に2ヶ月住むと体バッキバキに
なるんですよね
本当
でも
僕の中ではそれもすごいかけがえない
経験になりました
それから
帰国して
元々大学で
各関連の先行していました
でもなんか外に出て思ったことは
科学って
確かに技術を進んでるけど
全然社会
触ってないな全然接点ないなぁと思って
いや
ちゃんと
社会に設定を作る必要があると思って
科学研究とか
化学論文を
わかりやすくアニメーションに伝える
アニメーション事業と
科学の
体験ができる
科学実験教室の授業を立ち上げました
正直
ビジネスが
全くわからなかったから
めちゃくちゃ
散らかったなめんどくさかったなって思う
ことは
多かったですでもそこにはたくさんの笑顔
があって
僕を幸せにしてくれました
そんな
自分の
感情の中でいいなと思ったことを
実行しているそして自分の生還していく
そんなスタイルが
僕を幸せにしていました
しかしある時
自分の感情を
信じれなくなって選択できなかった時が
ありました
それは
先ほどの授業がやっていた時です
そうここで授業をまっちゃけミスって
しまってなんか落ち込んでって言いたかっ
たですけどいや実はうまくいってしまった
んですよね
彼の授業そううまくいってしまったんです
でうまくいった時に
周りの人々に
うわすごい社会的にいいことしてるね
もっとやっていこうよとかもっと高校し
たらもっと効果的になってインパクト与え
られたりとか収益性があってもっと良く
なるんじゃない」って言われてでビジネス
の本当にわかんなかった僕はそれいいな
確かにそうしようで思っていましたでも
そこの中には
自分の中であ
本当はこうしたいっていうのを
ずっと隠して
忘れて行っていた自分がいましただから
誰かがいいって言った
感情をそれが正解だと思って
誰かの
感情を自分の感情にして行動していた自分
がいましただから少しその中に違和感を
感じていた
そんな時にある友人がこの言葉をくれまし
た
感情には
賞味期限があるから
早くね
感情は
自分の五感で
受け取って感じるもの
受け取った時は自分の心の中をすごく占領
していてだからすごく熱があるんですよね
でもこれが
忙しい中で時間が
経っていくとただの
テキスト化された
g2になっていく
事実の感情には
自分の行動の原動力となるような
熱が
ほとんどないだから
流星が今感じた違和感は
熱があるうちに
ちゃんと消化して行動してほうがいいよっ
てその人は言ってくれました
そして
誰かの
感情の中に正解を求めていた自分に
誰かの感情になんて
自分の正解はないよ今
自分が感じている感情っていう大事な
チャンスが
目の前にあるんだからさそれを大事にして
正解しなよって
そう決めようって自分の感情を
選んでそれを正解してきたじゃんで
言ってくれました
それを聞いた僕は
自分っていつの間にか
誰かの感情の中で
誰かの時間の中で
生きているんだなってやっぱり
自分の人生は
自分の感情で
自分の中の時間の中でいきたいなって
そうやって
思った自分はよしじゃあちゃんと自分の
違和感は
紹介しようって決断しました
だから
自分の
先ほどやっていた
授業を
伸ばすことをやめて今
自分が大切にしたいことを大事にしよう
こうありたい
自分を
選択しようと思いました
正直振り返ってみて
自分が
積み上げてきたものを辞め
るってすごい何回も後悔しちゃうんですよ
ねまあ正直言うとでも
時間は戻らない
自分が
目の前にある事実を
選んだ選択した事実を
正解にしていくしかないって今ちょっと
話しながら思っています
まあこの話を
感情の賞味期の話を
僕のまた別の順にしたんですよね
そしたらその友人があることを言ってくれ
ました
いや確かに
感情に賞味期限ってあるねでも
感情も
賞味期限が切れる前に行動を移って
難しくないそれって理性が生まれつきその
環境でやってきたらできることじゃないっ
て言われたんですね
あ確かにとじゃあ逆に自分はどうやって
自分の感情を行動にしてきたんだろうなっ
て思い返しました
そうすると
意外とシンプルだったなって思いますそれ
は
形のない
自分の感情に小さい行動で
形を残していくことでした
例えば
受験とかわかりやすいかもしれないです
あーここいい学校この学校行きたいなーっ
て思ってよし
勉強しようで思う人は今まで多分みんな
経験したかなと思います
でも勉強しても
簡単に点数って上がるわけじゃないしから
あー
全然僕
全然追いつかないなぁこの大学やっぱ無理
なのかなーって熱が下がってきてそんな時
に
誰かがいやここ行った方がいいんじゃな
いって
選択肢をくれてで
熱が下がって自信がなくなってその誰かが
与えてくれた選択肢にすがりたくなって
しま
うそう
感情が小さな口座せないと
自分の熱が下がってその選択肢が選べなく
なってしまう
だから
僕だったら
例えばいい大学だーって見つけたらまず
その大学ってどこにあるんだろうどんな人
がいるんだろうどんなことが学べるん
だろう
過去問を見てどんな問題が出て
自分はどう問題が解けないのかなどの問題
が解けるようになったら
受かるようになるのかなーって調べるそう
やって小さな行動を
自分ができる範囲の小さな行動を積み重ね
ていく
自分の
感情を感じた感情の射撃が切れる前に
小さな行動を起こして小さな行動を
連続して積み上げて
いつの間にか大きな行動になっているその
大きな行動が
きっと
自分の行動を
自分の
感情を
肯定してくれるものになると
僕は思いますだから
感情の賞味期限が
切れる前に小さな行動を起こすということ
が
感情の賞味期限が切れる前に行動を起こす
という方法だと僕は思います
今日はまあ
感情の賞味期限に関するお話をさせて
いただきました
自分の
感情は行動の原動力
感情には賞味期限があってそれが
切れてしまうと
自分の
心の中で
ズルズルと
溜まっていってしまうその
消化しきれなくてズルズル溜まった感情は
どこか自分の自信をなくさせてしまう
自信をなくした自分は
誰かの
感情にすがりたくなる
誰かの感情にすがりたくなって
誰かの中に自分の正解を求めてしま
うだから
自分の
感情をから小さい行動してその行動を
正解していく
そんなことを今日お伝えしたかったです
皆さんは
嬉しいとか
悔しいとか今日常生活で
感じている
感情を大切にできていますか
もし今日この会場で
話を聞いて「あこれだとかあーあん時これ
すればよかったなーとかもし今思い出して
いたら
今日この後
皆さんはその感情をどのように
扱いますか
その感情を
賞味期限が
切れる前に
その感情を大切に扱ってみてはいかが
でしょうか
本日はご視聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]